the shock wave hit it caused the
refrigerator to get lofted and now it's
moving faster than the shock way well
that just can't happen my name is Greg
Spriggs I work at the Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory prior to that I
worked at the Los Alamos National
Laboratory in the critical mass lab
today we're going to be looking at
nuclear explosions and trying to judge
as to how realistic they are
play
actually that was one of the better ones
it had the right shape and it had the
glow time and the fireball eventually
cools and it cools very rapidly by
radiative heat transfer so the length of
time that the fireball continues to Glow
is referred to as the glow time it's not
over the bay it's clear of the city
these mushroom clouds can go up as high
as 40 000 feet in the air so you'd be
able to see it from way off there'd be
no danger from nuclear fallout unless
the wind was blowing directly towards
them so there's a general rule of thumb
if you look at the cloud the mushroom
cap
if it's white then you will have zero
Fallout for the most part if it looks
dirty then it means the dirt got into
the Fireball and now there's a carry
material which will bring the nuclear
bomb debris down and create local
Fallout so if you detonate it over the
water very little Fallout
people that were standing on the bridge
kind of felt a breeze that happened a
lot too soon it would have taken a
finite length of time for that shock
wave to make it out there and I would
give it a seven the flash was good and
the shape of the detonation was good
[Music]
it went off and then this plasma was
squirting out through that fissure
potentially if they actually could do
that it would break up the asteroid if
the asteroid is small enough it would be
very difficult if he had a large
asteroid to get a weapon big enough in
yield to cause it to completely break up
that would be
a very difficult thing to do
in outer space of course there is no
shock wave and if there was why would it
be disc shape it's a spherical shock
wave there would be a bright flash and
everything would cool within 20
microseconds so you wouldn't be seeing
this long glow time that they show in
the movie and people on Earth looking up
and seeing this white flash you would
see the flash but it would only last for
10 to 20 microseconds
if it's small enough and you could break
it up then it could possibly dissipate
in the atmosphere it could burn itself
out these two halves yeah that would be
very unpredictable from realism I'd give
it a one if you went in and actually
drilled into an asteroid and tried to
break it up how do you know it's where
it's going to break up into and where
the piece is going to fly this is a
matter of life and death
they were trying to hold all the cables
in place this was a test they were they
weren't certain that this particular
design was going to work and so this was
sort of the Prototype and they didn't go
to Great Lengths to make everything
really
robust so they were just basically
winging it with duct tape to hold things
in place and the actual one probably was
a little bit more structured and more
engineered to be a real weapon the
reason they suspended the bomb from the
tower they wanted to get it above the
ground so they could measure the shock
wave there was a lot of uncertainty
since it was the first one there was a
lot of uncertainty as to whether this
would work and if it did work
how much energy would be released and so
they needed to be able to film this and
they didn't want the shock wave
interacting with the surface they
thought that if they suspended it up
high enough that they would kind of
suppress the amount of nuclear fallout
that would occur by all the dirt being
lofted
that made a charged
they had actually built several shelters
for the scientists I think the closest
shelter was about five miles away and of
course everybody was wearing goggles
when the net detonation goes off it
would look very bright but it would
protect their eyes here are the glasses
very very dark
right now I can't see anything it's
Pitch Black in here but if a nuclear
detonation went off I could see it
they were all laying down thinking that
the shock wave might get to them and if
they were laying down that it wouldn't
be a direct hit you don't want to have a
big surface area if the shock wave is
coming over you want to be kind of
laying flat there have been situations
where we've had tests where the yield
was a little bit higher than what people
thought or the wind blew the bomb a
little bit closer to The Observers that
people have actually gotten a little bit
of a sunburn I don't think the sunscreen
would have helped very much it was it's
basically a heat flux that hit you I I
guess it would have helped a little bit
but not much for the accuracy of what
the weapon looked like and how they hung
it from the tower and so forth so maybe
a seven
oh that can't be good at all
[Music]
back in the 50s they were very very
conscious of showing the nuclear weapons
the weapon that was hanging off of that
Tower they actually had what were called
Tower cabs that were built up at the top
the cab itself had either plywood walls
or had some sort of curtain they were
paranoid that some other nation was
going to fly over and take a photograph
of what the bomb looked like the bomb
was just sitting here hanging off of a
cable
again not not quite true to history
the lead lined refrigerator kind of
struck me odd everybody knows about lead
poisoning why would you have a
refrigerator with lead in it you would
need several feet
thickness of lead in order to actually
knock down the radiation to the point
where he might have been able to survive
it if the house had a basement I would
have gone out gotten into the basement
that's probably the only thing that
would have saved him from the
thermoblast and from the shock wave
yeah
got several of the physics things
correct the first thing that happens
after a nuclear uh detonation occurs is
that you get a large burst of prop
radiation you get neutrons and prompt
Gammas coming off of the fissioning
process you don't necessarily see that
an observer might actually feel it if
they were in close enough and that that
would be a bad thing the next thing is
that the there's a a very intense
thermal pulse you get this very intense
thermal Blast from a nuclear detonation
that you do not get with a conventional
explosive and so anything that's close
to that detonation Point such as the
mannequins that they had standing out in
the front yards those would be
incinerated the time scale was a little
wrong that incineration occurs very very
quickly those mannequins would have
disappeared into a puff of smoke within
a couple tenths of a of a second
as for the glass the thermal pulse would
have gone right through it so the glass
probably wouldn't have shattered and
it's not until the shock wave gets there
that things actually get smashed
here you have a Shockwave and the car is
is keeping in front of it and then the
refrigerator is actually moving faster
than shock wave the shock wave hit it
caused the refrigerator to get lofted
and now it's moving faster than the
shock way well that just can't happen as
the shock wave goes out it eventually
degenerates into what we call an
acoustic Wave It's traveling at the
speed of sound so imagine this
refrigerator hitting the ground going at
760 miles an hour I don't think it has
the structural strength even with the
lead in it to withstand that kind of an
impact when the shock first goes out
it's moving outward and it leaves behind
a very low density bubble
where the detonation occurred which
causes a huge buoyant force and as that
bubble starts to rise it sucks
everything back in So This is called the
negative phase so in this case Indy
would not have been thrown out but he
would have been thrown out and then
sucked back in again
I I would give it a three in terms of
realism he got the thermal pulse right
and he got the positive phase of the of
the shock wave correct but the rest of
it uh
kind of fell apart
the subsidence crater
is produced
by a cavity that's created Underground
when the detonation goes off it
vaporizes the material but the material
is still there it's just in a plasma
state
and there's a lot of air spaces in dirt
and then Rock and what happens basically
is you get this very high temperature
very high pressure region underneath in
the cavity and it compresses everything
around it it's kind of like taking a
thick piece of Styrofoam and stepping on
it and it squishes it this this dirt and
rock surrounding dirt into this higher
denser layer which leaves the cavity
behind
[Music]
this is one of the problems with these
nuclear detonations in the movies as
they try to incorporate everything into
one shot where did that bright flash of
light come from if it was underground
you wouldn't see a bright flash
foreign
there certainly is a shock wave in the
Earth's crust and it moves very very
fast the way it was portrayed in the in
this film clip it looks like it's some
sort of a tidal wave of dirt bulging up
and then kind of moving along at a slow
pace and they've actually filmed this
they they did approximately 800 tests in
Nevada Test Site after they stopped
doing atmospheric testing they decided
they would do all the testing
underground there's no tidal wave of the
dirt
bunching up the way they showed it and
there would be no shock wave coming out
of the ground that would damage a
helicopter flying over
Shockwave took down a damn Chopper scmp
electromagnetic pulse you don't get an
EMP unless you have a detonation high in
the atmosphere which then can interfere
with communication electronic equipment
on the earth you generate these high
currents in the atmosphere you would not
get that with a detonation underground
they were trying to take all of the
basically understood nuclear weapon
effects and put it into one one
detonation underground and I would also
give it a one it certainly wasn't
realistic
foreign
[Music]
if you took a nuclear weapon you
detonated it out in true outer space not
in the upper atmosphere but in outer
space
what happens is the bomb would vaporize
because of all the energy that would be
deposited in the weapon itself there is
no shock wave in outer space Shockwave
can only occur when you have this
disturbance moving through some other
medium and they kind of show this ball
of gas which that would not be
associated with the nuclear detonation
itself too much mass involved with it
and also it would cool almost
immediately and you're in outer space
you get these radiative Cooling and you
would see a bright flash and it would
last for maybe 10 to 20 microseconds and
that would be go completely black
now the fact that they put this inside
of some sort of structure might have
been their fuel that was actually
exploding there not the nuclear
detonation you know if if this
explosion was propagating down the
length of this spaceship then okay it
lasts longer but if it were an
instantaneous kind of thing it would
cool almost immediately it was my least
favorite I'd give it a one
thank you
I have never even seen that before I I
don't even know what would cause a hole
like that I'm not sure where they came
up with that
if they had detonated this much deeper
down you may not have gotten a cloud at
all it's sort of like an underground
shot if you go deep enough you really
don't see the effect on the surface at
all when the detonation goes off it
creates this low density region and
basically would be a big bubble
underneath the water and that has a
buoyant effect and as it pops up it
causes this water spout
they do have the shock wave moving out
and the water spout does kind of form
these kind of shots do produce waves
they're not very big waves but they do
produce waves that's not something that
would destroy a an aircraft carrier
the Shockwave would have traveled
through the water and it would hit the
hull of the ship and there's a
possibility that when you hit it on the
side like that with a really strong
shock wave that it could cause antennas
on the on the deck to break but
certainly there wouldn't be a shock wave
above the surface that was causing that
to tip over during operation Crossroad
which was the first detonation after
World War II they wanted to see what the
effect would be
on the Navy Fleet if a detonation would
occur underwater so they took a lot of
the Destroyers and aircraft carriers and
they put them in the middle of the
bikini at all and they detonated the
shot under it the other ships ended up
getting a lot of damage from the nuclear
fallout again it was close enough to the
surface that probably the shock wave
would have hit the ships hit the hall
and could have caused damage but for the
most part it was mostly radioactive
material that settled on the onto the
decks
some Shockwave emerging from underneath
the water and then propagating through
the air knocking the helicopter out
probably not realistic but again I mean
if it were close enough it became part
of that water spout it would certainly
take out the helicopter again I would
give it a load Mark here maybe a two no
sir it is not a thing a Saiyan man would
do the Doomsday Machine is designed to
trigger itself automatically I have no
knowledge of any doomsday device in
existence this is a fabrication of
Hollywood
[Music]
they actually have to put the weapon on
a parachute to give the plane time to
get out of the way so as soon as they
dropped the bomb the bomb would drop
free fall for a while the parachute
would open and start going down slowly
in the meantime the plane would do a
hard right go we had 90 degrees and that
would make the distance between the
detonation point and the plane the
largest distance when it actually went
off has to be far enough away from the
detonation point that the the shock wave
doesn't destroy the plane
[Music]
film clip of the detonation was real so
he did go to the trouble of putting that
into the film I would give the
detonation a 10 and I would give the
rest of it sort of a a two